'Good morning Hank. It's Tuesday,' are probably the two consecutive sentences I have spoken most often in my life.
Its either that, or 'I love you. Let's get some pizza.'
Which you know I said to Mom when I was four,
and I say to Henry and The Yeti now.
Anyway it's Tuesday,
unless you're me in which case it's actually Saturday morning.
It's Saturday because later this morning The Yeti, Henry, and I are going on vacation,
and on Tuesday I will be on that vacation WITHOUT A  COMPUTER.
That's right, Hank. For the first time since I got this computer it's going to spend a night without me.
To computer: It's okay, shhhhhhhh shh shh Willy(the dog)'s going to stay too. Youll be fine. *mmmwah* You're okay.
Shh its okay, I know, I know.
Well Hank, the reason we are leaving behind computers on this vacation is that
I think sometimes it's good to reset your brain not to expect, like, a new celebrity pregnancy every day.
And more generally, Hank,
I'm a little worried that I've become addicted to the Internet.
Like a remember talking at the end of 2006 when we were talking about starting Brotherhood 2.0
Sarah said to me, "I dont understand how you're gonna do this because you already spend so much time on the internet."
And I was like, "no no no, making videos is going to replace my internet time,
"like the time I now spend falling down the rabbit hole of the internet, I'm going to spend making and editing videos!"
I mean, there wasn't even any Twitter! Or Tumblr! What did I do on the Internet in 2006, Google the weather in Dubai?
But, anyway, Hank, in the manner of an addict, I convinced myself that starting an online video project would decrease the amount of time I spent online.
Yeah. *pause*  No.
Now, Hank, I don't want the internet to be confused about my feelings.
I LOVE THE INTERNET.
Like yesterday, Henry and I spent 20 minutes on the Wikipedia article for Whale Sharks
Because we had a disagreement about whether whale sharks bite humans.
I don't want to brag, but I was right.
And to learn all that stuff about whale sharks cost us nothing.
And I also think that the community and connection I feel because of the internet has made my life richer and better.
However, I am looking forward to doing a lot of reading this week without
Every 4 minutes a little part of my brain being like, "have you checked your email there might be something important....."
So, Hank, with that said, I venture into a brave new world where human beings talk to each other in real life and
Breathe on each other and touch occasionally--it just sounds really germy
But I'm gonna do it because I think it's good for my mental health, particularly in advance of Carnegie *HALLLLLL*
Which is the sound that my anxiety makes.
And speaking of Carnegie Hall, Nerdfighters, if you don't have tickets to Carnegie Hall, I have great news.
There's a link in the Doobly-doo there are hundreds of places around the country and the world where you can gather together
to watch a live stream of the Carnegie Hall event, so go to that link
and find one and then go to one and meet new NerdFighters and et cetera!
And lastly, Hank, I'm really sorry if something terrible or excellent happened in the last, like, 3 days that I don't know about
And everyone's like, "why isn't he talking about this in his video??" BECAUSE I'M IN THE PAST!
Hank, thank you for the 53 wonderful terrible jokes, Don't Forget to be Awesome, I will see you on Saturday.
Everyone else will see you on Friday, but I get back on Saturday....I will see you then.